if there's one thing that I've learned
over the last two years of tracking my
sleep is how important it is to
prioritize and also how difficult it is
to really get a good night of rest even
if you think you're doing everything
right a huge thank you to ate sleep for
partnering with me on this video I am so
excited to show you this technology by
eight sleep that has helped me improve
my sleep significantly with their
temperature controlled mattress so this
is it this is the Pod cover by eight
sleep they have a few different options
and even entire mattress that you can
purchase but since I already have a
really great mattress that I love this
pod cover was a perfect choice now in
this set you'll get two boxes that
include everything you'll need your
mattress topper a water cord a hub and a
draining tool the initial setup is super
easy just get everything out of the box
and first pop on the encasement and then
the Pod 3 active grid that I'm sitting
on right here this fits on any bed just
like a fitted sheet it connects to this
little water Hub base station that
you'll fill with water and peroxide
periodically the water lets you quickly
adjust the temperature on each side of
the bed based on you and your partners
individual preferences and the phases of
your sleep and the environment that
you're in you'll be able to get the
mattress as cold as 55 degrees
Fahrenheit and as warm as 110 Fahrenheit
now before eight sleep I really didn't
understand how much temperature affects
your sleep a lot of traditional
mattresses trap heat throughout the
night and science has shown that your
body temperature actually needs to drop
in the early and middle part of your
sleep and rise in the morning so that
you can fall asleep fast and get more
deep sleep one of my favorite features
is how you're able to stay asleep with
automatic temperature adjustments
throughout the night to cool and warm
you I kind of like falling asleep with
my mattress set a little bit cooler so
this has been amazing because I now no
longer have to crank up the air
conditioning just to get my ideal
temperature I can simply adjust it right
in the app also what's super cool all
puns intended is when it's nearing my
bedtime it will automatically set my
temperature preference for my tired self
it also will give you a notification
that is preparing your bed for you which
is a nice reminder to start winding down
for sleepy time something thing that I
also love is that both sides are
adjustable so if you and your partner
prefer different temperatures they can
easily be adjusted to your preferences
and that's not it this is probably one
of my favorite things you can set a
wake-up alarm and the mattress has a
thermal alarm and it will also vibrate
to gently wake you up what's great is
that if you're also sleeping with your
partner you can get different timed
alarms and only their side of the bed
will vibrate or adjust temperature to
wake them and hopefully not you that
gentle wake up is so incredible and I
was so used to just waking up to an
incredibly loud alarm and it just
startles you like I feel like it just
makes my heart start jumping and I'm
like scared that something's going on
but with this gentle vibrating and then
even like the bed warming up like all of
those things kind of signal to your body
like hey it's time to get up and it's so
gentle and so calming and relaxing that
I can tell on days where I do sleep with
the eight sleep there is a huge
difference in my mood in the morning
this just went wakes you up gently and
you feel super Zen so when you do wake
up you'll get a full account of your
sleep and even receive notifications
about health changes for example if your
resting heart rate changes you'll get a
notification as an update so here is an
example of my sleep last nights you'll
get a sleep Fitness score you can see
mine right here you also get a Sleep
Quality you'll have a routine and the
time slept I absolutely love checking
out the sleep stages this gives you an
accurate representation of your entire
night's sleep as we scroll down you'll
see total hours of REM and deep sleep
we've also got our health metrics like
heart rates heart rate variability and
your breath rate your routine will give
you a readout of how you've been
sleeping over time and your consistency
this is also fascinating your sleep
latency there are nights where I will
fall asleep instantly and then there's
others where I've got this wandering
mind and I really could have been up for
hours and I have no idea how long I've
been laying there but with this there is
no question you'll be able to see it
right away I also really like being able
to quickly adjust the temperature on the
go like there are some evenings where
it's a little bit chilly out so if I'm
able to make my bed warm and toasty it
is such a nice treat this has taken a
little bit of time to get used to
because you will need to figure out what
temperatures you prefer so that was one
of the things that I spent kind of like
my first few weeks using this trying to
dial in do I like sleeping colder in the
mornings do I like falling asleep to a
more warmer or a cooler temperature and
what if I wake up in the middle light
and I'm a little chilly it's kind of
just finding and dialing in those
different temperatures and it's going to
be different for everyone so if you
don't figure it out on night one that's
okay because there are more nights of
sleep something else is pretty cool is
the fact that this is getting all of the
data right from the mattress you don't
have to worry about wearing any type of
sleep trackers and I think this may have
stopped a lot of people from trying to
track their sleep because they don't
want to wear anything while they're
sleeping so this pretty much alleviates
all of those concerns there are so many
factors that play into your sleep that
most people aren't even aware of how it
affects them now you don't don't have to
be as Extreme as me but I quit drinking
alcohol about seven years ago and coffee
about a year ago and these all play such
a huge part in your sleep patterns but
again you don't have to quit entirely
like I did now for caffeine the best
role is to stop drinking it about eight
hours before bed now as for alcohol
since most people do tend to drink later
into the evenings even if it does feel
like it helps you fall asleep you may
not actually be getting a restful night
because your sleep cycles can be
interrupted as the liver enzymes
metabolize the alcohol now the same can
be said for eating late at night which
is something that I have a bad habit of
doing you'll be trying to rest but your
body is going to be hard at work trying
to digest all of that food that you just
consumed before bedtime and I had no
idea before that so many of these things
would make a difference until you have
the data right in front of you so many
late nights where I've eaten those late
night meals or the big desserts or
snacks I can see that my heart rate
tends to lower later in the night which
is a huge sign that I might not be fully
rested so a few years ago before I
started actually paying close attention
to my sleep and how things affected it I
just felt so groggy I could still sleep
for I don't know like six to eight hours
and I still felt awful and I couldn't
figure out why I gone to doctors and
they're like well all of your blood
tests are fine we don't know what's
wrong with you so I started doing sleep
research finding different types of
sleep trackers and just really paying
more attention to how these things
affect you and I felt like I was so
close to getting that perfect night's
sleep and so many people kept saying
Justine you're obsessed with tracking
data you're obsessed with your sleep you
have to try eight sleep so that's where
eight sleep has come into this whole
picture and it really does feel like
this pod sleep cover has been the
missing piece in my search for achieving
the perfect sleep I knew that I like to
fall asleep in a colder kind of climate
so I would always turn the air
conditioning Down super low which then I
noticed like my electricity bills were
going up so now that I have this I'm
able to have my bed fully cooled ready
for me before I even get into it and
that also helps me fall asleep much
faster because I'm instantly at that
perfect comfort and temperature that I
like and it's so interesting because a
lot of people spend so much money on
different types of supplements sleeping
pills all sorts of things that really
aren't necessarily good for your body
they may help you essentially fall
asleep but some of the studies show that
they don't necessarily give you a full
night's rest so with things like eight
sleep being able to actually track your
heart rate your breathing and see these
changes over time it really does make a
huge difference and I'm so excited to be
able to experience this this definitely
has made a huge difference in my sleep
especially when I wake up like I don't
feel as groggy now there are times where
I definitely don't get enough sleep and
I'm able to see that data and with that
I just tried to adjust either going to
bed earlier or trying to be able to
sleep in sometimes for me I love being
able to get at least eight hours of
sleep about seven and a half feels
rights but when we start getting into
the five and a half range I know that
I'm not going to be having a good day if
you'd like to get more info about all
the awesome things that a sleep has to
offer I will put a link in the
description for you to check out the
starting price for the Pod cover set is
about two thousand dollars but it does
vary depending upon the size and model
you choose there is also two different
membership packages as well I'd love to
hear from any of you though who have
used one of these or if you have any
sleep tips to helping people get a
better night's sleep thanks again for
watching I'll see you guys in the next
vid